[Music]
the night pants nation tour continues
got some one night stands in june june
24th des moines iowa june 25th omaha
nebraska june 30th praia california
what's up chico
yes sir
get your tickets to those shows and all
shows on my website at
ryansickler.com come on princess
[Music]
come on girl
[Music]
june shows coming up june 24th i'm in
des moines iowa one night only june 25th
headed to omaha nebraska one night only
and back at brea california
june 30th one night only as well get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler i want to say
thank you for your support i appreciate
seeing how this community grows and
supports one another you guys are the
[ __ ] uh if you are watching
on
youtube please hit that subscribe button
i'm telling you it helps it helps all
right and if you gotta have more we are
now over a hundred episodes on the
patreon
and it's called the honeydew with you
all and you all have the wildest [ __ ]
stories i can't get over what i hear
every week been doing it now for two
years just sitting there listening to
you guys tell stories just a few weeks
back sharing an episode with josh wolfe
highlighting 10 of my favorite episodes
and it was received so well i think
we're going to be doing more of that
tour dates des moines june 24th one
night only omaha the 25th one night only
break california june 30th uh now you
know what we do over here we're
highlighting the low lights we're
looking for a little bit of that light
in the darkness i always say these are
the stories behind the storytellers and
it is a pleasure to have this young lady
back on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome back raylen
nelson welcome back to the honeydew
raylen nelson thanks ryan thanks for
having me back you're very welcome thank
you for being here um before we get into
what we're going to talk about today
please plug promote everything that is
raylen nelson um music is funny podcast
listen to that wherever you listen to
your favorite podcasts and you can watch
it on youtube
and then
raylandnelsenband.com i just put out a
new single called free go check it out
on the youtube channel at raila nelson
band don't go to raylyn nelson.com yeah
uh i just found out that what happened i
don't
own it anymore i thought i owned it and
had it forwarded to raylan nelson band
but when you go to raylennelsen.com it's
an escort
you know naked lady you know you just
get some sex there but isn't it for like
older women or older people yes that's
what it says today
it changes every day
it's a surprise every day no way i
thought it was like
if you wanted to get some ass in your
60s or something like that there was one
of those ads on there i saw that too
yeah
so you don't own that anymore huh
apparently not
so go to raylandnielsenband.com
or you can go support those ladies
you know what go get some [ __ ] go get
some cedar citizen [ __ ] at rayleigh
nelson.com y'all
go get your jackpot
i feel a little flattered that somebody
would want to put that yeah you know
there's worse things i guess there are
definitely worse things
um so
welcome back and look i know i said what
i wanted to talk to you about earlier
but i i actually do want to talk to you
about worse things because i was
communicating with you during this but
you had a stalker situation yeah can we
go there first yeah and i say that
because
i don't know if they'd be comfortable
with me talking about it maybe they
would but i'll keep the ladies names out
but there are three ladies in comedy who
also had a stalker situation um to the
point where the police had to go
to the guy's [ __ ] home and it is
since that helped it sounds like he
listened good um but you also had a
scary situation yeah so i checked my
grandpa's fan email
and
it it's actually pretty cool because
it's i can just reach out to people and
it says it's from willie nelson and
literally if you get an email from
willie nelson you're probably going to
open it so and i did ask my grandpa for
permission to do that so it's really
cool that i have this email address but
a person started emailing quite a bit it
was like anywhere from 60 to 150 times a
day claiming day yeah a day claiming to
be papa willie's son
and
so real quick if you don't mind
how many kids
i mean he could be palpably son i hear
you on you know right right but how many
kids does papa willie know he has
uh
um
lana suzy and billy were from my
grandmother billy is my dad
and then there's amy and paula from
connie
and then lucas and micah from annie so
seven seven two but then there's one
that came
about
a legit one yeah okay but it was she was
actually his first kid because before
my yeah this is kind of interesting so
before my grandmother and papa willie
got together so i mean he was probably
16 or something right
uh
he had a one night stand with a girl she
got pregnant
she gave the baby to a couple in a bar
no yes this is like 1940 let's see he
was born 33 so
i'm not good at math what is that 48 49
you know this is like 1950 something you
know so she gives it to a couple in a
bar that couple raises the baby
um
when
renee was probably 30 years old she
contacted papa willie
like called him somewhere in a hotel
room like tracked him down somehow told
him this
yeah think how hard that would have
[ __ ] been um
yeah so that would have been in the 80s
right so then she contacts him he's like
yeah all that story checks out and she's
like well i don't want anything i'm very
happy with my family
uh but you know just wanted to let you
know i was here and he was like okay and
she was older at the time
she was probably in her 30s oh wow i
think you know i could i could be a
little off on numbers i'm really bad at
numbers but uh so then
like 12 years ago
she contacts the family and she comes
back into our life
listen i remember when i said i didn't
want any money
well
[Music]
yeah listen
[Laughter]
so
how about jewelry you don't got any
jewelry i don't need cash
not quite like that
[Laughter]
but um my cousin noel her daughter's
daughter needed some eye surgery that
you know she was going blind and needed
some surgery
and uh she you know wanted some help for
the surgery and papa willie of course
did it but when the first time she came
on the bus
the first thing
rose yeah
what's it like being on a honeysuckle
can we hold on for a second
it's my favorite thing literally it's
101
the only one of the only reasons why i
want to be a musician because papa
willie's always toured in that tour
that's all i know as his home really i
know he has houses i've been there but
he's always been on a tour bus when i
would visit with him
and the bunks were always so much fun to
play in
um he sits at the table you know the he
has his spot nobody really sits there
except for him
there's always a um a serving
uh
do you remember those old serving trays
from shoni's that are just kind of like
circular
yeah yeah it was weed on it and ready
you know a joint ready to go
um
anyway
so she gets on the bus she gets on the
bus and he goes she looks like raelynn
and she's about 60 at this time because
this was only like a like
15 years ago or so 12 15 years ago
and so she looked like an older version
of me obviously but
they did a dna test then and it was true
and uh but yeah that was aunt renee
she's passed away now she had breast
cancer i actually never met her i only
talked to her on the phone
yeah i only talked she sent me a hat
though
yeah
so
go ahead sorry
i'm in a row so she's dead so she's gone
but
did she get an inheritance or
her daughter noel is still in the family
of course she's still a part of the
family the surgery go well
the surgery oh that's going blind
wait are you
i can't tell right now i can't tell you
the surgery didn't go good i like that
you can't tell i don't want to lay up
it's a poor kid who's might be blind
because it didn't go good yeah it didn't
go well
it wasn't [ __ ] she still just it
just didn't
it didn't do well it was like right when
stem cell
surgery was new you had to go to
thailand to get it done
yeah it was in thailand i wouldn't i
mean maybe if i was going blind i would
i want to do some cell stuff i think
it's
yeah pretty miraculous yeah not in this
case apparently but no
yeah she's also the 80s
now what this was just like 10 years ago
or so that's when she came back into our
lives you know
i wasn't even alive in the 80s i'm so
young okay so
the reason we sidetracked is because
that is a
as we know a blood relative this stalker
situation okay is i know i'm good at
what i do you're good at this is a
questionable at the time you're saying i
don't know he could be yeah because
right you know my grandpa's a rockstar
he's had a lot of sex a lot of sex yeah
yeah it's true he could have kids out
there right that we don't know about but
uh he's just kept singing sending songs
he's was sending batshit crazy stuff i
mean he he would go through my social
media and just start writing a movie
script with people uh that i was doing
podcasts with and just talking [ __ ]
about all these comedians in the movie
script like it was part of the nails
you're getting
long novels of
he was just crazy you know
uh so then he's like i'm gonna come to
the house i'm gonna come to your house i
he was based in florida he said he was
gonna come to nashville he found my old
thank god i moved he found my old house
on
you know on um wherever you can find
where raylen nelson lives when you look
at his house.com yeah
actually that might be a [ __ ] secret
is
oldbox.com
ryan he did he showed up at my house and
um
he showed up at the old house yeah the
old house uh the restaurant that i used
to work at down by my old house i went
there and asked the the same old ladies
worked there that were there before it's
like a little meat and three do you know
what a meat in three is
uh
in the south we have a lot of them it
basically just means like a meat and
three vegetables
so they have like salisbury steak and
country fried steak and then you can
pick like green beans mac and cheese
whatever so it's one of those
restaurants and uh i showed him a
picture because he was sending pictures
of himself too and they're like yeah he
was here
uh so
anyway
how old would you say he is roughly or
did he say i ever said i don't know i
don't know
older though he would send pictures of
his
or his dad that his mom told him it was
he looked just like him ryan and he'd be
like i don't look anything like
and
just like i got a mustache man i don't
have a mustache and then with some
pictures of him and lucas my uncle or
him and
uh
or him and you know papa willie and
claimed to still be it was just
ridiculous but so yeah we had to get the
fbi involved and the egg went as far as
the fbi yeah and is that because of your
grandfather and [ __ ] too like they want
to make sure this guy doesn't go after
him also yeah basically
damn yeah but it was really good the fbi
shows up at your house what's that
feeling or they um they basically call
you all the time they didn't show up at
my house but they just called me all the
time and then i have one well he could
have showed up at my house he's only a
couple miles away the the detective that
was
you know put on the case and right near
me but all he had to do was call him and
tell him to stop or we were gonna press
charges and we haven't heard nerium i've
gotten one email from him maybe like two
months ago and it was a song and i
didn't want to alarm anyone so i didn't
you know and he hasn't said anything
since but did you have to leave your
home and [ __ ] like that
the kids wanted to go stay with their
dad obviously so they were there and i
didn't get he was literally in town
yeah
in town i'm nuts he um claimed that he
was going to the willie nelson museum
which is where we do the podcast so of
course i had to alert everyone there and
we had to stop
you know podcasting for a while damn it
also yeah you don't know when he left
right
no well he was keeping me luckily he was
so crazy he was just emailing you know
um so he did tell me when he left but my
kids still didn't feel my boys were kind
of my boys are 15 in a couple weeks so i
wouldn't trust that yeah they they were
kind of like i'm i kind of want to just
come back home i'm not worried about it
but my daughter was like
you know so then um the detective
actually talked to my daughter and
that is what finally made her feel
better and she came back home yeah thank
goodness that feels like such a
long time ago but it wasn't that long
ago i mean you and i were talking
through the whole thing
just letting you know what was going on
and everything my ex-husband went and
taught me how to shoot guns yeah
yeah
yeah
that's i i feel
anybody that does that goes through
something like that it's nuts to me i
was watching what this guy was doing to
these girls too and just you know yeah
it's scary [ __ ] even when they call you
and tell you like this happened i'm like
what
it's [ __ ]
yeah they're crazy people are crazy yeah
scary yeah um all right i want to talk
about another creepy person in your past
actually
can we talk about this this van
okay i want to talk about this
because i have a daughter who's seven
and i wanna i wanna know so many people
have sat in that chair and told me
terrible [ __ ] stories
so so i was about 16 years old and i was
going to student life camp at church and
what is student life camp
it's a camp where you
like a non-denominational christian this
was baptist actually oh really
this is a baptist church that i went
with
uh do you know what the difference
between what makes baptist baptist and
it's stupid [ __ ] it's like versus
methodist they don't dance in the
worship music it's very it's like hymns
yeah that's what i went to
[Music]
people were speaking in tongues and and
like jerking really dancing i was on the
dance team oh yeah oh yeah you're doing
that i remember being seven years old
and this lady praying over me to speak
in tongues like she was trying to like
pray this into me
and she's like
[Music]
and i was just like that scare the [ __ ]
out of you yeah and she was like just
move your tongue and i was like
i just repeated what she said you know
because i was seven years old
and
a child it wasn't like the spirit came
over me or anything
yeah it was just it was a weird church
but the church that i was talking about
this was a baptist church it was way
more laid back than that this is in my
teen years
and i didn't tell anyone about this
until i was about 26 years old i think
which was just last year
but uh
forever 27. there were 27. so
in um you know those
church vans and those white church fans
look like pedophile vans anyway with the
extension on the back yeah actually
that's what my band van is you know
[Laughter]
you might want to paint it
i've thought about it i thought about it
we actually do need to paint it because
it's already anyway so um sit just
sitting there and one of the counselors
was sitting next to me in the van it was
a couple of seats back and all of a
sudden he just
stuck his hand i was wearing shorts he
just stuck his hand up my vagina
inside you yes
and i froze ryan like how old was he
he was 19 or 20
and i was 16. i knew i know i was 16
because i had driven to the church and
parked my car there
and um and i just kind of froze
and couldn't move at all
and just like let him do
that to me
and it sucks because i if i could go
back now of course i'd be screaming in
that car to everyone else that was in
there all the other 15 people you know
or 12 people that were in there
he's putting his finger in my vagina and
i i don't know why i didn't i was too
scared i didn't
i don't know why questions
yeah like had you had any experience
with boys before that or is that like
not much about your first experience not
much at all
that's terrible
no like just
like innocent making out
nothing like that
and i was i didn't even know what it
what he was doing you know really you
didn't say something
why didn't i say stop i have no idea
and i didn't tell anyone except i
remember when i got there
i was feeling super uncomfortable about
it so i told some friends who were
dating at the time a guy and a girl
justin and tiffany and i just said that
he tried to hold my hand
that was like that's
as comfortable as i was at saying what
happened because you were embarrassed i
guess i was embarrassed you know
but i don't really know why i was
embarrassed but i definitely was and i
blocked it out i didn't tell anyone i
didn't want my mom
to
not let me do anything anymore i was
barely allowed to do much anyway because
i was going to church camp come on you
know for fun
so
i knew she wouldn't let me do anything
if i did you think she would blame you
like you would get in trouble for it
somehow
i can't do that your 16 year old mind i
guess so you know like why didn't i tell
her i did finally tell her eventually
maybe just a few years ago when that
really go mm-hmm what did she say and
she said it wasn't my fault yeah it's
not all i mean
we just bawled and bought you know like
i'm so sorry i didn't tell you i didn't
you know it wasn't that it i don't even
know why i think i just didn't want you
to ground me from my car you know it's
such a stupid reason
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i didn't want to you know like what
would you do in that situation if your
daughter came and told you that oh you
know what i'll go do it going down to
that church [ __ ] church yeah
and if that was me that caused that you
know
so can i ask you was your dad gone at
that time did your dad have oh yeah my
dad died when i was seven seven mm-hmm
so here you are with no dad this is
happening you don't tell your mom you
don't tell anybody but what did they oh
but you only said held your hand
you never said anything to him did he
ever did he ever try anything ever again
no no did he ever sit next to you again
nothing nothing
nothing and i stayed away from him
do you remember his name don't say it
yeah you do have you ever tried to look
him up david kuffman
wow yeah i'll say his name he [ __ ]
did it yeah go for it he married some
girl from the youth group
and he has kids
yeah that's not a great situation and
in no way were we dating or did he ever
you know even ask permit nothing no just
sat next to you and we were just in
youth group
jesus christ
yeah we used to see the but it was it
was called the church of the open door
okay that was the bus the van that would
ride through our neighborhood and that
was what was creepy too it would roll
through your neighborhood yeah and just
stop like you kids want to come and it
was the same van you're talking about
but it was powder blue
yeah it was called the church of the
open door and some of our neighbors
would get on and go and we're like we're
not gonna [ __ ] getting on that
[ __ ] you could see the faces in that
[ __ ] van just looking out like help
me we're like we're not getting on that
[ __ ] heaven
dude the church in the open door
[Music]
i'm going to start church of the closed
vagina
so why
10 years and who did you finally tell
was it your mom that you finally told
first like when you really started
talking about this my sister mm-hmm
she's had a lot of trauma and
you know she's had a lot of
she hasn't put herself in the best
situations at times so
and she said that herself so i'm not
saying something she doesn't know but uh
yeah so i opened up to her about it and
then
um she
you know
my
my mom and step-dad's best friends
they're uh
i don't even know if i should talk about
this but
the
husband made advances at my sister
and this was just a few years ago and
then
when my sister finally came forward and
told my mom and her dad about it
uh gave me like the courage to i don't
know it gave me the courage to talk to
my mom about it because that was really
hard for her to do
jeez the dad
the husband yeah i'm not sure if he's a
dad or not oh i see what you're saying
but they're no longer friends obviously
yeah holy [ __ ]
and my sister wasn't
a child but she was 18
which is
16 and a half come on you don't go after
your [ __ ] no best friends children
anyway regardless of the age
yeah um but especially sorry mom
but it's true that that all happened you
know i want to tell you a story i just
thought of
uh
i
outed
on accident found my mom's best friend
this was
early on i was still married so my
ex-husband's sister
had a best friend okay your
sister-in-law at the time
had a best friend and he he was a gay
man he okay
and he found my mom's best friend's
husband on the gay sites on myspace this
is my space states so it's like the
myspace sister-in-law's
husband no so my sister-in-law's best
friend is a gay man
and he
found who
okay so my mom's best friend who was a
lady right her husband through church
right so i grew up with these people in
church
yeah always biggest freaks and looking
back it's he was so obviously
gay but i didn't
know that you know
um
nobody told me that the quality the gay
qualities were that was that what that
meant i could see there was a difference
in them you know but i didn't you know
nobody ever said that i didn't know that
until later and he was definitely just
and he but
i told melissa my mom's friend i was
like hey you're uh your husband's on the
thing and she divorced him
he and now he's living his best life
there it is you know because he's with a
man you know he's living his best life
now
um
oh church stories my uh pastor from
church
is uh is now transgender he and did porn
out here like yeah
your ex-pastor is a transgender porn
star
a beautiful one she's beautiful
she's beautiful
she lives probably right down the road
oh that was fantastic got far away from
nashville and became a woman and
religion probably too and the other one
before that uh had an affair with the
lady in the church you know
like this is why
church is so hypocritical oh yeah oh so
hypocritical yeah that's why i don't
want to have anything to do with it
because i don't want anyone to think i'm
a hypocrite you know
they're the most judgmental
the most [ __ ] up i say it in my set
every night the the hierarchy of
scumbags in this country starts with in
this world starts with the catholic
church
it starts there and it is not open for
discussion not at this table
so but ever but people hide behind this
religion thing they hide behind that a
lot of the [ __ ]
obviously they're not all bad people of
course no but the bad ones use this god
and jesus or these deities to hide
behind this and
you know all you can be forgiven for
what you did to that girl in the van you
know
do you think that guy ever [ __ ]
thinks about that
do you wonder no i wonder how many
other girls he's done that too or even
if it's his kids
yeah you know you never know
um oh i just thought of something else
my uh sister's
best friend when she was 13
told me that her dad was [ __ ] her
wait
yeah hold on
her own father i'm confused
your sister's friend's own dad incest
we're talking yeah
why and her brother
the dad was [ __ ] the brother
no the brother was [ __ ] her
maybe
maybe
i'm not trying to miss this is horrible
but i'm good there's a lot
holy [ __ ] the dad was [ __ ] the
dad and the son are having sex with the
his daughter and her his brother yes
jesus christ
yes and uh
said that they would
she said that they would put a um like a
bag or a pillow over her face
yes at the same they're together doing
this the sun's doing this i don't think
they're doing it together jesus christ
well where is the son learning that of
course it's his dad it probably is
happening about him too and the mom was
super pilled out
so uh she was just sleeping all the time
and didn't
you know wasn't
living life you know
so uh i tell my mom you know i'm like
and i'm like 22 and not that long ago of
course
i'm like 22 at the
you stay consistent on it i'll tell you
that um
and
my mom was like hey raylene you're an
adult and a child just told you that her
dad's [ __ ] her you're gonna have to
call
this dhs and say it and i was like
what so she kind of
you know walked me through that uh and
you did you made the call we did
everything we were supposed to do
um
unfortunately the
once it got to the point where the law
got involved my sister's friend was like
never mind nothing i lied nothing i know
i know it's so sad and then
and it sucks because uh
they were really close
and they weren't allowed to talk anymore
you know she they weren't friends and
they were the type of friends that are
for each other not the competiti it's
hard to find girlfriends that aren't
competitive with you at that age you
know at 13 14 years old
so
it's really sad they're still not
friends and they still don't talk and
it's you know
been girl do we know anything about this
no she chose to
say she was lying
and
her parents are keeping it hidden except
until i talked about it here
i hope it comes out
i hope i hope some truth comes out of
that yeah god
you guys know we love liquid iv here i
love it i start every day with liquid iv
uh we have bags of it here at the studio
for all our guests that want to take
anything and it's one of the things i
love to give away
on the shimiya show at the comedy store
that i'm doing tonight i'm throwing bags
of liquid iv out it's great stuff and
i'll be honest i didn't know how much it
cost until you guys started telling me
how much you save
uh using the honeydew so when you're
pushing your body too hard or you're
just feeling run down it's extremely
important to stay hydrated making
hydration a priority helps us feel
better on a day-to-day basis and what i
like most about liquid iv is how easy it
is to take along with you no matter
where you are you just drop it in and
you are good to go one stick of liquid
iv hydration multiplier in 16 ounces of
water
hydrates faster and more efficiently
than water alone it contains five
essential vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and
vitamin c
it's got three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks and it's made
with premium ingredients non-gmo and
free from gluten dairy and soy grab
liquid iv and bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off i think i said 20.
25 off when you go to liquidive.com and
use code honeydew at checkout that's 25
off of
anything you order when you use promo
code honeydew at liquidive.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code honeydew
celebrate all that you are and explore
who you can be with customizable
prescription glasses from pear eyewear
look some people like to put on tennis
shoes some people like to wear a t-shirt
whatever it is for your style to say
whatever it is if you're into the eyes
i'm telling you right now you can change
your glasses like you change your
clothes get started by choosing your
base frame with options from the square
to the cat eye look every frame comes in
six different color ways and then you
pick your top frames and build a
collection to match your personality for
every pair purchased pair provides
glasses and vision care for children
around the world so you're doing a good
thing listen here's the cool thing i got
my pair um i was worried about sometimes
i don't like the real thin glasses
they're not they're not too thin they're
not flimsy they're sturdy glasses and
then they got these really cool little
magnets boom and you pop them on i'm
telling you when you turn the side you
can't tell you cannot tell that you have
a blue blocker or a sunblock or whatever
on there i promise you they are legit
you can get glasses as unique as you are
one pair infinite style starting at just
sixty dollars go to pair iware.com
honeydew for 15 off your first purchase
that's 15
off at p a i r
dot com slash honeydew have you ever
just been too damn high well with
today's weed it can be a dangerous game
and we don't always have time to play
reefer roulette when we're looking to
light up that grass is reviving the
pleasure of the casual smoke so you can
chill out without the stress that grass
is legal organic smokable hemp that
relaxes your body and mellows your mind
their 100 percent organic pre-roll
joints are very low in thc and high in
cbd so you can enjoy the effects of cbd
while keeping a clear head if you want
that toke without the smoke that grass
also has a cbd tincture made with the
same high quality hemp it's like having
a glass of wine not the whole bottle all
dad grass products are federally legal
for ages 18 and over and it ships right
to your door anywhere in the u.s so
whether you're looking for a new buzz or
a chill way to enjoy an old favorite
daggrass will leave you in a euphoric
mood i'm going to say this to you right
now if you're trying to quit cigarettes
and you just like the habit of smoking
try dag grass right now all right they
also have mom grass i smoke both of them
i take them on tour with me sometimes
after shows and i chill out i promise
you it's good stuff if that's your style
right now dadgrass is offering my
listeners 20 off your first order when
you go to dadgrass.com honeydew go to
dadgrass.com
for 20 off your first order that's
d-a-d-g-r-a-s-s
dot-com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
doesn't that [ __ ] stat this is the
[ __ ] that that keeps me up at night
thinking about things like this that
there are people on this planet that can
do things like that i know you know like
i'm
my daughter's seven doesn't want to even
do a sleepover yet because she's still
too scared to sleep in her own damn bed
sometimes so good yeah good yeah but i
am petrified when she goes to a
sleepover at someone else's house like i
want to know is there an uncle lives
over there
who's got guns in the house i want to
know every male figure every female
figure that's there who's there how many
people were there it sounds crazy so
it's best just to keep them all
you know
until they're teenagers you know when
you have to oh you're you're a singer my
kids go and hang out at their friends
they do and they're 15 and stuff now but
but
um
you know when they go to their dad's
house the way my daughter goes to her
mom's it's it feels like a different
planet
you know what i mean like they're
traveling away somewhere i feel like and
there's just
you can't keep an eye on them i know the
way you want to facetiming all the time
though right
do you remember that time we were on the
phone
and you saved stella's life
yeah that was before you did the first
episode yep i was i believe right yeah i
was doing a solo show in tacoma i'm four
for five and you called me and um i was
smoking weed outside the hotel
and i was like hey ryan i just lit a
joint and you go oh are you token
and i was like yeah i'm smoking a joint
and then you're like oh and i hear the
phone shake you're like god call you
back
so you know you said stella's choking
yeah you thought i said token yeah
you're like
i've ever said toking either no
i don't think i ever say that no but you
were just like are you choking to stella
but i thought you said to me are you
talking and i'm like yeah i'm just
smoking weed and you saved her life you
called me back like within five minutes
like she's fine she just had some meat
again that's the second time i've had to
do that for her first time she got
something stuck in her throat
um it was me and her mom and her we were
sitting at the table and she got up and
this was a while ago she got up she
walked away i thought she was going to
get something to bring it back to the
table to show us and when she turned
around and came back i looked at her
face and i was like oh my god you're not
breathing and she was trying to tell us
but she was walking back and forth so
her mom didn't know what to do and i
gave her the heim like boom that [ __ ]
shot right out because you know you do a
smaller one when they're little
you don't double
so then this time
thanks this time
she had i don't know if it was a hot dog
or what the [ __ ] it was pizza was a
pizza yeah it's right it was pizza and
she had it stuck and she couldn't
breathe and she came to me and i did it
again it shot out onto the balcony i
took that piece and threw that [ __ ] off
but yeah i've had to do that i mean you
talk
about anxiety i will never forget the
time my younger brother um choked on i
think it was steak at my grandmom's
kitchen table it was or dining room
table i should say it was my dad her and
me and my two brothers and he was legit
going down and my dad got up and did the
heimlich and that [ __ ] steak shot out
onto the table and i that's always stuck
with me like man so
i even when if i'm in the back of the
house and i hear her cough and i'll run
out and she'll point to our water like
it just it went down the wrong way i'm
like are you good you're good i don't
want to be doing this [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm
four for five rest in peace grandma
uh i remember my mom jerking me out of
the back of the car when i got a light
remember those little lifesaver holes i
don't even know if you can get those
anymore or they were just like the whole
of the lifesaver and they would sell
those as a candy and i got one stuck in
my throat my mom was driving a trans am
and i was in the back hell yeah pulls
over and jerks me out of the back and
throws me upside down she didn't
she didn't know nothing about it she
just threw me upside down like shaking
me and hit me on the back he worked with
him
yeah
oh that is a panic um also when my boys
were in the nicu uh i was holding one of
them and one of them quit breathing in
my arms
but i had no idea i just saw all the uh
they had they were all hooked up to the
machines so i heard alarms go off and
the nurse very slowly and easily just
walked up to me and she goes this baby
isn't breathing
and she goes all you need to do is just
rub his chest right here and she just
started rubbing his chest and then the
alarm stopped going off no way
yeah
i mean
i'm like did my baby just die in my arms
and all i had to do was rub his chest
and i had no idea
yeah how many people probably lost
babies like that in the old days didn't
even know it was just a little palm rub
on the chest well my boys were born
eight weeks early so they wouldn't even
one started taking over the other one's
blood when they were both inside of me
they're fraternal or identical so it's
weird they have so identical twins
have one sac and one placenta right
and then for
i know so you had your own sack
and your own
placenta right and basically means that
two sperm hit two eggs because she just
happened to release two eggs so it's on
the mom's side
and then if it's identical twins it's
one sperm it hits one egg and it splits
for some weird reason right
and
my boys
had um
one placenta two sacks
so is this so what's that called is that
a name for that no but they look a lot
alike you know and they have uh they're
the tenth set of identical twins in
their dad's family
so
uh
anyway i'm put on bed rest
like at 29 weeks of uh pregnancy is
about 40 weeks with fraternal twins
we'll call for ternicles somewhere
between fraternal and identical yeah i
love it all right
um so they're inside of me and then i
one day i get a real bad migraine and um
i go to the doctor my blood pressure
skyrocketed and if your blood pressure
skyrocks skyrockets when you're pregnant
they immediately admit you and try to
see what's going on
and they did an ultrasound and um they
they did this like um it sounded like a
train horn to the babies on the belly so
they on one side they it was like
right and then to the other baby once i
have to like test their
test their like if they because they can
hear right so aiden the baby a at the
time like immediately did this big jerk
and they did it to brodie and he went
like just this tiny thing and the doctor
said that baby is dying we need to get
him out he's gonna
they're gonna uh do better if we have
them in the nicu now so immediately i
mean thirty minutes later they were born
it was that fast you woke up with a
[ __ ] headache and next thing you know
they're taking babies out of you because
one's killing the other one yeah wow yep
um and it and the fun thing is may 22nd
um that you know twins are two twos you
know i was in room 2222 i was 22 years
old at the time it was like all these
twos that i felt like okay i feel like i
don't know you just draw comfort in
these weird things and those moments
right
um so they're born but they had to stay
in the nicu for uh the neonatal
intensive care unit for three weeks
and so i just pumped breast milk every
two hours and took it down there to them
would freeze it
uh
just cry that i couldn't be with it i
know what's that like can't be with your
babies when they're first born there it
was just it was so much
how long ago it was worse it was worse
than losing a parent i think because
it's just
there's this overwhelming feeling that
you need to be with a baby
and i was there i was there every single
day i went down and visited that every
single day and took the milk because i
couldn't
bear not to it was like my i was just
magnetically drawn i stayed as long as
the hospital would let us you know but
then when we had to go home i just kept
going back every day cause you were
going home you weren't at the hospital
staying there oh i'm thinking you're
walking down a couple floors and you're
right there you got to drive how far is
that each way i mean it was
20 minutes you know
and uh the neonatal staff there was
great you know but it was just so hard
to leave your babies especially
overnight yeah
so then they came home
they weren't even supposed to be born
yet uh so there they came home one month
before they were supposed to be born
and so they were just little bitty teeny
tiny and they would uh they were great
you know i feel like i got more baby
time than most people because they were
here a little early but i would never
ever wish that upon anyone
uh and you know you'd see other babies
in there that had been in there for like
two years and they were still so tiny
just hanging on for life and their
parents were coming in
every day
yeah the songs that were on the radio at
that time uh when i hear them now i
immediately want to cry again
because it just goes through but
like at the time i remember
that daughtry song do you remember the
guy that won the american idol uh that
home song that he had it's like i'm
going home
to a place where i belong something like
that
and uh every time that song comes on it
that feeling of oh my god i gotta get to
my babies and i can't
it comes over me
but then um so then i got into
uh i get pregnant again and i get into i
want to have a
a v back which means you're going to
have a vaginal birth after a cesarean
section because my cervix wasn't
competent after my twins they wanted me
to have a
they wanted me to have another c-section
and i was like i want to try natural you
know it was until the natural it's
called a v-back
and doctors hate it by the way
uh because
if they do a
c-section it's covered under insurance
everything's neat and tidy but it's
still
major abdominal surgery i mean i can't
like
i've seen some of them where they put
they're putting the [ __ ] out on the i'm
like
oh yeah i saw scott's face when they
were opening he was like i was like
don't do that don't do that but he said
they ripped me open like a t-shirt he's
like oh
get up
and then just like put me back
[Laughter]
holy crap so the same doctor that saved
my boys
he
was my doctor for my daughter and he was
saying that she needed to come out that
she was overdue and it wasn't true i
don't think because when she was born
there's these signs on the bottom of
their feet that um the wrinkles on their
feet if they have them all the way that
that shows that they're 40 weeks and she
didn't quite have any there so that it's
more like a 36 37 week
either way she was born too early she
took in a big gulp of amniotic fluid so
she basically had pneumonia because she
had liquid on her lungs
and had to stay in the nicu for a month
longer than my boys even had to even
though she was technically born at 36 37
weeks which is
you know you a lot a lot of times just
babies are really good i can't have
healthy babies for some reason you have
healthy and it was really hard yeah
everybody's good now of course when she
finally came home it was the best time
ever you know and she
i didn't even know i wanted a daughter i
thought i wanted to be a boy mom you
know i was all into being a boy mom and
then as soon as i saw her in the nicu
after because they immediately took her
away just like the boys and um and i saw
her and i was like there she is she's
mine i want her give her to me you know
uh and she's the best she's literally
one of my best friends it's like it's
cool you get this you know you're just
like creating your own best friend one
day
as having being a
it's so funny
how madrigal's daughter is 16. um i
think he said she's six one or six two
oh and i was asking him what it's like
to be you know shorter than your
daughter because i would be yeah um he
said she's also like you know she's
lifts and stuff and she's like a really
kick-ass volleyball player
and
he said you know up until now
he's like you're how old your daughter i
go so i saw him at the comedy store uh
the 50th and we were talking in the
kitchen and he's like he goes oh my god
this is the best time right now he goes
he goes it's like right about now until
about for me two weeks ago
he's like she was my best friend doing
everything like dad dad dad and then
it's that age where it's like you
know what we all get yeah yeah
yeah
so what is it like i want to ask you
this
i mean your dad passed when you were you
said seven
i mean what is it like parenting
with do they ask questions about your
dad like do you do you talk about your
father as much i know you're only seven
so you know do you keep him alive so to
speak in the household and if so what do
you do
i think they don't bring him up much
because they know me they don't want to
make me sad you know like i'm doing
right now
[Laughter]
so
yeah um
yeah they don't they don't bring him up
much that being said we talk about and
there's pictures of him up you know and
my boys look so much like him they do
yeah
and
so i know that
just as much if we can look like our
people you know how how much on the
inside is like us you know like it's
um yeah because you don't know your dad
like that after no only seven but people
tell me i'm like him in certain ways and
how is that i haven't been around
yeah little things like that
that's that jeans that's jeans yeah so
just like you can look like them you can
just kind of be like them
how old was your dad when he died 33. do
you ever think about when your kids are
33 how it's gonna make you feel [ __ ]
like that
yeah yeah and
you know them at the same damn time too
yeah i know and there can i only have
just three years left with them before
they're just gonna be taken off and live
in their own life it's
it makes me not want to be away from
them too long i only want to go do
one-offs you know or a couple shows here
and there
so i can be back with them because i
only have a short amount of time and
they're already doing school all day and
then
playing piano and then working out
they're into working out these days and
then they want to play with their
friends so
you know we get dinners together which
you know if you instill that it
everybody knows what dinner time or you
know whatever me whatever time the meal
is have at least one meal of the day
where everybody gets together and just
talks about what's going on you know
and i always have check-ins with them
i'm like check-in time how do you feel
about life what's going on
and
you know they'll
they'll i feel like we grew up together
i really do so i feel like we're all
just good friends as well as you know
obviously like they never
they haven't been mean to me yet you
know what i mean like we haven't had to
deal with uh like don't talk to me like
that i haven't had to do that since they
were very teeny tiny you know like
but um
i don't know where i was going oh i'm
pretty sure it's coming anytime soon my
daughter is 13. she just started her
period for the first time oh yeah i'm
telling everyone and she hates it she's
like
seventh grade eighth grade
yeah sixth grade she's in sixth grade
almost seventh year okay she started
kind of early a little earlier than i
did
i just remember in middle school when we
were going to the nurse's office for you
know our cuts and injuries it was this
lady with i mean a [ __ ]
mountain of tampons and maggie pads
behind her like like the room was
sponsored by him you know what i mean
like that's how many were in there i'm
like i'm just here for a band-aid just
like looking at code text and [ __ ]
wrap around your fingers and tampons i
don't know the difference i don't know
anything like what the [ __ ]
yeah have you heard of these free
bleeders
yeah there's these um period panties you
can wear and then you just let yourself
just bleed
and then just toss them out they wash
them no yes no you throw those away no
you wash them and reuse them it's called
thanks you can get them at thanks.com
you throw those away promo code
[Laughter]
yeah did you know people are manifesting
things when they're orgasming now what
do you mean
so yeah you should try this the next
time you have an orgasm okay okay
so
you uh
you just start manifesting things that
you want during the orgasm and it's like
a magic time that you can create make
things happen did you charge your
crystals i you know i charged my
christmas okay we just got back from
sedona
wait
are you telling me to take myself out of
my orgasm no no no because he listens to
me orgasm and mentally
i realize you can't think of those
things to get there but once you're
there and you know you're you're not
you're in that
once lightning is striking yeah and it's
like that
throbbing feeling that's the time you
should be like
money money money or what do you want to
manifest you know health and happiness
for stella
that's kind of weird way weird yeah
yeah but did you supposed to yell that
out loud too
i i bet it works better if you do
huh but i i also think maybe you could
just think it
and it'll work
so try that out try the theory let me
know if you see me in a house in santa
monica in the next six to eight months
to a year you'll know it does
see
can it be self-love too or does it have
to be with a person no masturbating is
better oh is it
for self-managed so it's just keep it
all to yourself yeah it's magical it's
magic right orgasms are magic they are
magic yeah
all right
um okay now let me go back switching off
to a second of manifesting in my orgasms
back to you parenting
um do you ever think about what would
happen
if something happened to you
having that hindsight of your dad's gone
do you ever worry about hey what happens
to my kids or that's how i justify
praying protection around myself because
for them for them i don't want them to
lose their mind panties
free bleeders is that what they're
really good thanks they're called
thanks.com seriously they were
free bleeders
they have no shorts no have sleep shorts
yes
and it's kind of amazing like even if
you do
even if you use a tampon they're kind of
cool to have just in case things well
that's different though that's different
i know every every chick's got their
period panties already they kind of work
heavy flow they have one for light i
can't believe you don't know about this
why would i oh yeah i guess
maybe stella would be into it okay but
wait let me now let me go back to you as
a woman tell her she's a free bleeder if
you
do you think you'd be comfortable
wearing these
i do wear them you do yeah but i also
wear tampons i can't stomach not wearing
the tampon i'm saying only those i mean
sometimes yeah if i'm day one if i'm at
home what'd you do i can't do it all
night in the world that's what i mean
would you go out and function and walk
around cause i'm scared
i would just feel like i had diarrhea in
my pants all day at any moment it's
gonna drip down my leg that's what it
feels like that's what i suggest from
your vagina yes that's what i'm guessing
i don't know why
you can totally feel it come out and
everything
yes
all right back to uh
the serious question
for real
do you have any do you have anything in
place do you have a plan with your
kid's father about other than praying
for protection
no
uh they would obviously go to their dad
and stepmom and my mom would definitely
be a huge part of their life because she
already is
um i mean obviously i have life
insurance in case something happens you
know
my grandpa all of my dad's stuff would
go through fly a lot you know
thanks for bringing it up right i'm
bringing being practical what are you
doing
you fly a lot too what do you think i
had to go get therapy to get on these
damn planes
it worked though damn it it worked i
could sleep on a plane now adam ray
caught me on a plane sleeping hell yeah
it worked i can't believe it worked i
used to [ __ ] love taking off i felt
like a rock star flying like that
[ __ ] plane shooting down the runway
and we're going up in the air to go
somewhere yeah and then i get [ __ ]
terrified of every [ __ ] who every
turbulence and [ __ ] terrified yeah and i
was like i have to do this so i know i
got to beat this and now i'm i mean
that's my i still get adrenaline when
we're [ __ ] shooting down that damn
runway and we're taking off but
and landing landings the landing has
never bothered me ever
i feel good about the landings i'm like
we're here mm-hmm you know i've had a
couple dicey ones where you feel like
you know or they're they're going way
long when this thing stops stopping yeah
yeah i got a couple of those yeah yeah
and then i've had where um
just turbulence really bad twice where
you're like well this might be it and
this is how it happens because you know
when it happens it starts like that
the turbulence i've read turbulence can
never crash a plane i've done extensive
research but if the plane is crashing
it's gonna feel something like it's not
gonna feel smooth yeah
you know what i mean it starts like that
yeah
it's not gonna be like just eating the
next thing you know yeah
yeah
which would be okay maybe you know it's
gonna be terror it's gonna be terror and
it's gonna feel a little bit like that
so
that's maybe why
but yeah you know
and the more we fly the more likely it
is like you said well i don't know the
more we drive the more likely it is same
flying is the safest way to uh travel it
really is statistically it doesn't feel
great all the time but it is the safest
it's that control thing i'm on the
ground i have my hands on the wheel i'm
in control of this i can't i say it all
the time it's not like i can get out of
[ __ ] 33 c and walk up there and be
like move
let me fly this you know what i mean you
just stuck maybe like oh god please do
the best you all can do today yeah i
know and what if they just got in a
fight with their boyfriend or girlfriend
all that [ __ ] yeah
like are you focused today and they
always look 18 now like 16.
the pilot i had last time i wanted his
shaved head here and then that zoomed
over and i was like you're the pilot he
said yes look at you man up there
never expected to see a pilot with a
haircut like that yeah like punk rock is
[ __ ] yeah yeah
that's cool um
okay so i want to talk to you a little
bit more about your dad all right
can we yeah you all right with that yeah
um
like what do you what do you miss the
most
i miss that i didn't get to know him as
an adult
you know i wish i i know i wish i could
have a conversation with my dad now as a
grown man yeah
ask him what they were thinking and all
the anything like he had [ __ ] twins
in 1973 like what were you doing dude
yeah yeah anything and him just coming
by the house to watch a game with you or
something
or smoke a joint with you think he would
smoke a joint with you i think
that's a really good question because my
dad preached
no drugs because he knew we were going
to do them eventually but it was always
no no no no no but dude was in vietnam
you know in the navy not in the jungle
but in the navy during vietnam i should
say and it was always no drugs so i
didn't that's the reason i didn't start
smoke until i was 21 cause i always felt
like i was letting my dad down yeah it's
the only reason and i'm glad because all
the studies i've read say
it really does [ __ ] up your brain
uh
up until about 21
if you're pounding it when you're 16 17.
yeah so
i i answered i it's funny i said this on
joe rogan years ago
i know what i would do if i had 24 hours
with my father what would you do if you
had 24 hours i mean talk about a sun up
to a sun-up
just you and your dad no i shouldn't say
that because you you want to meet your
kids yeah we'd have dinner with the kids
what would you do start with the day in
the morning sun's up
um
would be weird if he was just there so
maybe i would just meet up with him
but yeah i want to like uh make coffee
for him and smoke a joint with him
and be like where the hell have you been
all these years what are you doing
yeah but like what was he thinking what
was he doing i would want to find out
all the questions what happened you know
all the questions i have i would want to
answer what what give me some of the
ones you think about a lot how did how
did you die did you take yourself out
did you even think about me and my mom
when you did that
uh man
what would you have done differently
um
what was going on between you and my mom
when y'all got divorced
tell me everything about papa willie
when you were growing up yeah you know i
never get to hear stories from him
uh
i would
want to go ride horses with him he loved
riding horses and the cowboy thing so
i'd want to go do that
and
i and then i'd want to go see my grandpa
i'd want papa willie to see him you know
so i'd want to go to a show and
have dinner with everyone and
all the family be there and which never
happens you know right and he'd want to
drink beer and we'd drink beer together
and that'd be cool be drunk with my dad
did you ever get drunk with your dad
before he kicked
nope
16.
i mean i'd only gotten drunk maybe a
couple times before he died yeah because
you're so young yeah um
i mean i'm not gonna get drunk but you
know like yeah the first time i tasted
beer like he gave me a sip i was
probably like middle school and at
fourth of july but wouldn't drink
anything one sip and i take it i was
like oh man you drink [ __ ]
i don't remember [ __ ]
it was probably natty bow or something
like that schlitz schlitz schlitz
um it wasn't coors light i'll tell you
that
um of course light's delicious delicious
um
okay why
can i say this you asked me
to ask you some questions you would ask
your grandfather
and i wrote those questions down too and
you're like i cannot ask that oh
what did you ever
talk to your grandfather about your dad
not really no you've never asked him
what was he like as a son a child or
nothing we don't bring him up because it
makes him sad
you know and and it just sounds like the
same thing you said about your kids not
bringing your dad up
and if he brings it up
uh it's he's like your dad would be
proud of you so he'll say things like
that but he won't talk about he won't
give you a story
i think he i think he regrets not being
more involved in his life at that minute
and
uh not really knowing what was going on
because
there were times that he did get him out
of trouble right before that so he would
have helped if he could have you know
and um i just
feel like he feels bad for not being
able to be there when whatever happened
you know
but
you asked me what you thought he would
say
and i think it's the same thing
which is
what happened because none of us know
what happened right
um and then i think he would say i'm
sorry i wasn't there you know i wish you
were in texas or i wish i was there i
would have done anything to help you and
my my dad knows that my dad lived like a
like somebody whose dad would take care
of him if he did anything you know
so
um that's what what was the other
question you asked well i'm basically
asking like
without
because this is his son
so i'm sure there's guilt there with
yeah of course but we would all have
that right but also
hell yeah you're going to live with that
the rest of you even if you're not have
nothing to do with the death we're going
to feel guilty when they die
because you're not supposed to die
before you're supposed to die before
your kids that's right you're not
supposed to outlive your children that's
right your kids are supposed to bury you
yes that's the natural circle of life
yeah yeah so that's
you know
but why
just as a historian of your dad this man
has these stories you don't think you'll
ever get them
you think you do you think there'll be a
chance at some point they'll come out
when
you know my aunt amy and i are
i think i mentioned this last time we're
calling as friends and getting
information getting stories
so we just have to ask everyone else you
know that's the best way
um i know papa willie's
super upset gets super upset and we
don't want to upset him you know
we want him to be happy
oh renee passed away remember the first
one but okay you know she was only close
to our family in the last few years of
her life
so it's different than my dad yeah
um it was his first son willie nelson jr
yeah you know
um
yeah you know
uh
my it's funny stories pop up at the
random at some random times my aunt
bobby who played piano for my grandpa
she just passed away yeah
uh and
we i just happened to be playing in
texas in austin
and or right outside of austin
so i flew my band back and i stayed for
the burial and it's like she held on for
when i was there or something it's kind
of neat
or not even me i think it was about my
dad because
when i was there at the burial
uh we're all there and everyone's just
kind of saying some stuff about aunt
bobby
and i said that um i was you know young
when my dad died but my mom always told
me that when
aunt bobby walked into the room my dad
would light up and he would stop and
take a minute and go over and hang out
with her and talk to her and get her
whatever she needed she was
she was the female star of the willie
nelson and family band right
and everybody treated her as such she's
queen
so
uh i said that i said my mom always said
that uh
he would light up and so i just picture
since he's in heaven and she's over
there now that he's just lit up and so
happy that he's there that's nice and
you know a couple people like yeah there
are angels or whatever and then
aunt bobby
her son that's living she had three sons
and she lost two boys
within three months of each other
and they were um they were like 37 40
years old when she lost then i mean can
you imagine oh
so but her
son that's living is married to a lady
named lisa and lisa goes
raylen i'm so sorry to bring this up but
since you brought up your dad i have to
tell you a story so in front of everyone
my dad kind of jacked the you know jack
the funeral and lisa tells this story
about when her and freddie were getting
married
everybody was up there singing some
really lovely songs playing guitar at
the reception
and my dad comes marching in his chaps
grabs the guitar from the guy that was
singing
starts singing this like you you're
cheating heart song you know like
something really shitty and everybody
was doing all these love songs and he's
doing he starts doing like a you cheated
on me and [ __ ] you song and uh
and then
he gets done everybody's just staring at
him and he goes y'all singing about love
i'm trying to tell you how it really is
and then everybody started
yeah and everybody's like
and she tells the story everybody laughs
at the funeral and i was like holy [ __ ]
if my dad were alive that is exactly
what he would have done here at this
funeral this barrel everybody's so sad
and
you know when that grief just hits and
you just can't stop crying everybody was
doing that and everybody stopped to
laugh at a story about my dad and i feel
like he if he was there he would have
done that so yeah
um it's neat because you end up hearing
stories at weird times but it almost
like it makes him still here you know
they're still here and they can still
affect
what's going on oh no doubt
no doubt
listen i know this wasn't easy for you
so
you covered a lot
yeah um thank you for coming on
thank you for we're gonna go to the
comedy store later yeah we can go to the
comedy store okay thank you for making
me laugh
thanks for making me laugh at your
trauma
um and again please plug promote
everything and anything you would like
raylandnelsonband.com
[Laughter]
didn't you lock it in for at least a few
years yeah yeah i think i'm just gonna
keep it i was gonna like why it's fun
uh yeah and then go check out the new
single free on our youtube channel music
is funny podcast ryan sickler you're the
coolest thank you raylen nelson for real
i really appreciate you coming back
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you